know what that was my witch powers hey
guys and welcome to cozy catch-up
halloween edition today we're gonna be
talking about everything spooky and
scary kind of the same thing but it's
October so let's do this so before I
start talking about my favorite scary
movies games and a bit of manga I'm
going to have to warn you that terror
will be haunting the streets of London
if you don't know who Tara is then shame
on you if you don't know who do is you
can check it out in my other video that
I did all about a figure called terror
who terrorizes everybody really go watch
it check it out it was part of an
interactive video than I made and it is
coming to London this Halloween I'm
freaking excited download a lot Tara
Tara come come here come say hi al them
all about when you're gonna go to London
to scare them and stop you know come
here come here no he doesn't want to be
on camera but he will be in London the
28th till the 30th and so I I'll be
there to make sure he doesn't actually
hurt any of you guys you're very welcome
we will be at Moss fest basically Mars
Fest is a festival in London and it's
the world's leading festival for the
open Internet movement you know Mozilla
Firefox it's basically that just in a
big festival you'll be able to
experience my interact video who is
terror in the interactive way that it
was supposed to be seen which I'm
freaking excited about so I will be
there at Mars fest all weekend I'll be
in demystified the web which is a little
section of Mars fast do let me know in
the comments if you're going to be at
most first I would love to see your
faces just someone smiley and friendly
that I might know of back on to the
topic at hand let's talk being scared
how do you scare ya grin I'm going to
tell you exactly how to scare me and
throughout my lifetime what has made the
most impact on my life and my love of
horror
so let's start with games gaming was one
of the first reason why I started to get
so intrigued in that horror world and
being scared and the adrenaline rushes
and everything else because when I was a
kid I had a PlayStation 1 and I had some
friends down the road who had a game
called alone in the dark a nightmare
wait no let me say it properly is that
good anyway it was a ps1 game yeah two
disks and it was the most terrifying
thing I probably still ever played I'd
never played something here before I
know they presently because that's my
equivalent of the classic retro horror
game I'm not sure how many people
actually play that game and are a lot of
people played and learn in the dark on
PST but please no just no it's it's not
the same it's a let down if you played
that when you're thinking yeah man and
learning in the back with the robert i
plated unpleasant ooh i know it was
rubbish but trust me this one on
playstation 1 a new nightmare was
terrifying i am a huge fan of fixed
camera angles i think that they really
helped to accentuate that fear because
you can hear what's going on behind the
camera but you can't see and you have to
walk towards it so all you know
something's gonna jump up right in front
of you in front of the camera it's just
freaking terrifying you don't get scares
like that anymore they said you started
off it's either a male or a female and
you could either start with in this
house that was really dark as the girl
and she didn't have a gun so you had to
shine torch lights on to the monsters
and they didn't like the lights or he
could be the man he could be outside the
house and you do start off with a gun
which is good but creepy things still
happen and because of the creepy camera
angles it kind of switches every now and
then and you can see one camera angle of
a person looking at you through the
window and you're still walking and it's
like you can hear this person green
just watching you will pass the window
it freaked me the hell out let's move on
to the next game the next game was when
I was a little bit older and I had a
Playstation and I got this demo pack
siren blood curse was on that demo it's
Japanese game if you didn't know I don't
think many people know of it but it is
bloody terrifying because the Japanese
they know that horror they know how to
freak the freakin tits of you and I love
it I can't even explain it it's just
messed up it's like zombies but not hey
just pictures pictures there you go and
you can't really kill them they always
come back to life oh and you can see
through their eyes and it's just the
most scary thing I'm not doing a very
good job fix things the last game might
seem a bit strange and it's definitely
probably the least known it's called
gregory horror show it was a game that i
would just play all the time I found a
number that i found it in game station
sending remember game station and it's
just like on the slide it was secondhand
and I thought what are these weird
polygon II characters because basically
it's from a Japanese TV show the
pleasant sleep night
you'll be needing it believe me I got
turned into a game it's really dark for
how cute see it looks because it doesn't
look like a cute little children's TV
show but there's a lot of really dark
undertones for instance my favorite
character is a little girl and she's
constantly looking for her dolly turns
out that actually the doll she's looking
for is on the other side of her head and
it's stitched on there so she's forever
just in this limbo of eternity of
looking for this doll that is actually
attached to the back of her head I'm
sure it would make her feel big and also
possesses her and makes her kill you and
there's a ton of different characters
like that that are just as morbid but I
just chose that one because she was
definitely the most terrifying one when
I was a kid if you got something to say
tower just come in and say it it's fine
just so you know I'm doing live streams
I've been doing them for a while but I
made them a weekly thing now so please
come along now on to horror movies cuz
you can't be a good horror movie around
Halloween now the first movie that
absolutely terrified me and made me
unable to sleep for months was the
Exorcist and I know I'm gonna get a lot
of weird comments about that scene and
the excess is rubbish it's so old but
bear in mind i was a thirteen-year-old
girl I'd never really watched a horror
film before I want to see if someone
puts it on now I love horror movies I
don't want to watch that I just I just
can't because I honestly could not sleep
for months and it just scared the hell
out of me especially the fact that they
said it was based on a true story and
i'm a very gullible person okay and the
second is actually the pact I don't know
how many people have watched this cuz
like i have mentioned it to a few and
they don't know what i'm talking about
or they think it's the purge it's a film
that seems very generic in horror terms
it seems like it's all about kind of
supernatural and ghost haunting a house
but the twist at the end that I'm not
going to ruin it for you just blew my
mind and made me stay awake for a few
nights just wondering what if at
happened to me just watch it scary and
the last horror movie which isn't really
a horror but I've got to say it because
it is one of my most favorite movies and
just the fact that it's so dark and
morbid makes it a horror for me is the
orphanage I'm not talking about the
orphan basically it's about a mum who is
looking for her son missing and she
finds all these supernatural things and
the helps that she's living in to you
think that something's happened with
that perhaps ghost of taking the boy
away but I'm not telling you the ending
is traumatic tragic crazy mind-blowing
you'll stay with you it'll stay with you
and if it doesn't what's wrong with you
it stayed with me since I've watched it
and I want to watch it again now it's
it's really really really good and now
on to mango but I've just really got one
thing to say about this subject which is
junji ito and I have only just found out
about him really in the past year but I
am obsessed if I can't sleep I will read
one of his short scary stories basically
he's a manga artists key is just a
genius when it comes to horror he plays
on the most simple ideas of what could
be scary or gross or unnerving and just
knit picks at it until it becomes almost
unbearable to see on page and the way
that he draws these images and brings it
to the viewer is just amazing every a
Qing that he does just seems to have
been done so intricately and it just
makes the whole thing a bit more
unnerving to look at it's really
difficult to describe how he's able to
do this within his drawings cuz even I
don't really understand it it's very
simple but it's just kind of eerie is no
best for you zoom a key which is a story
that goes on about a city that becomes
obsessed with the spiral shape you see
what I mean it's such a simple concept I
was like how could this become scary but
oh my god it is beyond scary is
stabbed and I love it so much but also
he does a bunch of short stories that as
i said i have been reading a lot of and
luckily for me there's tons and tons of
tons of them and one of my favorite so
far it's glyceride which is about a
family who live in a kind of flat made
of Greece because they live above a
restaurant that has ADD ventilation
basically people start drinking Greece
they get a little spotting this boy ends
up just popping his foxhole or as
sister's face and it sounds weird me
just as many it like that but honestly
Oh read them if you want to be scared
and if you're maybe not at a television
screen and you don't have a game or you
don't have any money to buy these things
go online and just so good junji ito was
amazing and not to mention that he was
working with hideo kojima on silent
hills that's how good at hora he is it
hasn't been mentioned whether he's
working on death stranding but I really
hope that he is because the thought of
him working on some Hills made me so
happy until it wasn't a thing anymore
but you know we don't talk about that
anyway now it's the time of the cozy
catch-up where I am so few of your
questions that you left in the last Cody
catcher Florida de varela I'm so sorry
I'm so bad at reading names she said I
just wanted to ask a tough question i
hope you'll notice i have noticed would
you rather have bad breath or bad body
odor you can't fix them oh my gosh why
you can't face them as in i can't even
fix him temporarily so if i had a mint
it wouldn't go away just for a little
bit or if I sprayed it wouldn't go away
just for a little bit us that's hard so
if I had bad body odor no one would ever
want to be near me then if I have bad
breath I just never be able to speak to
them leave it or not I'm a little bit
quiet anyway so wouldn't be too bad not
talking okay I'm gonna have to say I'd
breath if I can't fix them at all bad
breath if I can fix them temporarily I
body odor and I just take a heap ton of
do de with me everywhere I went Ethan
games says have you got any advice for
me AG man eat your greens because your
body needs all the new tree
sometimes when you're hungry you think
that you're hungry but you're not your
body's just starved of nutrients that
it's not getting from the greens and
stuff so really do your greens go
outside because if you stay inside you
end up being enclosed in a little bubble
you forget the beauty that surrounds you
outside your bedroom learn something new
every month ago that's my advice for you
Ethan games new you are neighs if says
can you tell us about the software
you're using for editing recording and
all that stuff because I think you're
pretty good at it perhaps if you can
make a video that would be helpful if
more of you want me to make a video
about how I make my videos and
everything else what software I use what
cameras i use and everything let me know
in the comments below and i will
definitely do that for you guys but i
can say quickly now i actually use
imovie a lot because especially in these
vlogs well i'm not going to do too crazy
editing it's just quicker however for my
gameplays because i like to have my my
face of the top and it needs to be a bit
smaller and I'll used Premiere Pro i
also use what's this thing that i'm
using audacity to record my voice which
from my microphone which is just down
here when I'm playing my game play I use
QuickTime to put the screen and I use
sound flower to record the audio it's a
little bit different because i'm using a
mac which is crappy but it's okay
because I'm gonna get a pc soon don't
worry about it thank you for watching
this cozy catch-up halloween special do
let me know if you check out any of the
halloween stuff that I just recommended
to you guys I really hope it can freak
you out a little bit because it
definitely freaks me out also let me
know if you're going to be at ma's fest
this weekend i'll leave the link in the
description below also ask me some
questions for next cozy catch-up and you
might be featured in the video every day
or evening fine
hi guys happy Halloween for this
Halloween I thought I'd talk to you
about my paranormal experience